[Music]
hey guys it's a girl congratulations you
have any idea who the father is
well 30 time all right let's go
three two one this is dr. David Jordan
our mission is to intercept a research
pond for Mars 16 steps to fix a shower
I'm an astronaut not a gym teacher this
is the first capsule ever to come back
from the clinic we have visual
confirmation I said this could be a
major scientific breakthrough come on
come on come on come on Wow you
Instagram we're looking at the first
proof of life beyond a lowering oxygen
more carbon dioxide that's beautiful
you finally a daddy it's gonna be a big
custody battle over this one I wash it
back tears no we're gonna keep it up
here gonna study we're safe
you can't fastest-growing every single
cell is a muscle cell I don't have cell
muscle one brain how smart is this thing
[Music]
these creatures wiped out Mars
millions of years ago if we let it get
to earth well risk all human life
let's kill the thing good night moon
good night room good night cow jumping
over the moon goodnight light red blue
what is the Providence stink of any
life-form to survivor good night stars
we've lost all communication good there
look at the atmosphere in 39 minutes we
hunt by branching but it could
goodnight mr. this everywhere
but I think it's time we're looking at
the first proof of life beyond Earth you
finally a daddy